[Musique]
capio bienvenus bonjour bienvenue ici a
look to you pour votre café politique
vous êtes conseillère départementale des
yvelines maire adjointe des locaux en
charge de l'éducation et du numérique on
va parler de votre parcours de vos
engagements et puis bien sûr des
dossiers que vous portez ça fait
beaucoup de sujets à aborder au cours du
prochain avec ardeur pour débuter
peut-être la reconstruction de votre
famille politique
j'aurais commencé par ça aujourd'hui la
droite est en reconstruction puis un
match no 1 an dans les yvelines
notamment à l'automne il faudra désigner
un nouveau responsable départemental qui
est votre candidat
pierre bédier le président du conseil
départemental ou alexandra dimanche
conseil régional alors du coup
effectivement les républicains se
remettent des dernières élections
présidentielle et législatives 1 où les
résultats ont été pour le moins
inattendue et a surpris effectivement
notre famille politique
l'état de notre parti sur sur le
département et et bien été à la peine
faut quand même dire les choses quand
même voir des postes de députés ont été
ont été perdus voilà il nous en reste
plus qu'à un monde grâce à pierre bédier
d'ailleurs donc moi je pense que
ils on part de loin il nous faut
quelqu'un d'expérience
il nous faut quelqu'un de terrain et à
mon avis pierre bédier incarne un peu 7
comment connaissances expériences voilà
du terrain et des gens du terrain c'est
un homme c'est un humaniste qui qui
connaît bien les sujets de notre
département donc à mon avis voilà je
vais effectivement je souhaitais en
chantier remédier et vous pensez ensuite
que l'union de la famille de droite ce
sera possible
forcément forcément je d'ailleurs voilà
c'est bien dommage d'en être arrivé là
parce que voilà il n'y avait pas il
aurait fallu qu'on se mette d'accord dès
le départ je ne suis pas pour leur
contre le renouvellement évidemment des
hommes politiques sur sur le territoire
est ailleurs mais là la situation fait
qu'il ya urgence et il nous faut
quelqu'un de d'expérience aujourd'hui
aux républicains vous vous y retrouver
justement est ce que laurent wauquiez
par exemple incarne bien votre famille
politique qu'à écouter laurent wauquiez
est un homme de valeur c'est vrai je
pense qu'il faut lui laisser sa chance
c'est vrai qu'on entend beaucoup de
choses voilà ça a tendance à aller vers
l'extrême droite tout ça je suis pas sûr
que ce soit bien fondé c'est un homme de
valeur il faut lui laisser sa chance et
avancer or encore une fois on part de
loin aux républicains il faut qu'on se
reconstruise vous avez adhéré quant aux
républicains
alors en fait moi j'ai adhéré un peu
tard j'ai adhéré en 2003 parce que je
connais jean michel fourgous depuis 96
je n'étais pas encarté à l'époque mais à
force de le fréquenter sans doute je me
suis dit qu'il fallait que que j'adhère
aux républicains qui est effectivement
une famille dont je partage les valeurs
et les idées notamment pour l'éducation
des monts
mon sujet favori et le numérique et donc
voilà j'ai toujours été dans ma vie
engagé mais pas forcément politique
j'ai été présidente de fédération de
parents d'élèves la pub pour pas la
citer j'ai toujours vrai dans des dents
des sujets qui me passionnait et donc
pas au bout d'un moment je me suis dit
allez vous avez vous êtes passé
j'imagine en tant que militante et
adhérents des républicains par tous les
sentiments ces dix dernières années 15
dernières années entre les victoires les
défaites ces derniers mois ont été très
difficiles
oui bah oui je peux pas dire qu'on est à
sauter au plafond voilà mais je crois
que quand on est convaincus de nos
valeurs et encore une fois des idées on
se décourage pas et ne pas se décourager
il faut continuer et voilà je suis sûr
que on va retrouver on va retrouver nos
nos lettres de noblesse vous avez évoqué
jean michel fourgous qui est donc le
maire d'elancourt que vous avez rejoint
donc pour ses différents mandats au sein
du conseil municipal de la ville
d'elancourt vue avant ça vous étiez vous
l'avez rappelé aussi au sein d'une
fédération de parents d'élèves pour vous
l'évolution était naturel vers
l'engagement politique
oui naturel parce que en fait en 2003
jean michel fourgous était député à
l'époque à vue et on avait créé une
association qui s'appelait ni cette île
terrain et qui est vrai pour l'apport du
numérique dans les apprentissages
scolaires et donc au fur et à mesure des
projets
j'ai participé à ces deux missions
parlementaires une qu'il devait être en
2009 sur l'apport de l'outil numérique
dans les apprentissages scolaires puis
en 2011 un deuxième rapport qui avait
été commandé par le premier ministre de
l'époque qui était sûr maintenant on à
l'outil numérique
comment est-ce qu'on transforme la
pédagogie avec l'outil numérique pour
faire réussir les enfants donc au cours
de ces deux missions parlementaires j'ai
effectivement rencontré beaucoup de
politiques a beaucoup d'échelon qui
parlait de ce sujet et donc pour moi oui
ça a été naturel de m'engager en
politique pour faire avancer les
dossiers et vous vous étiez un moment un
jour ou l'autre je ferai de la politique
c'est quelque chose que vous aviez envie
quelque chose dont vous aviez envie
quelque chose que j'ai toujours été
intéressé je suis d'une famille qui a
toujours été intéressé par la politique
il était républicain à l'époque ump et
voilà oui mon grand-père était
conseiller général il y avait un gène
quelque part qui fait que je pense que
naturellement je suis arrivé à m'engager
en politique alors à travers le biais
justement du numérique à l'école pour
aller en cours mais aussi pour le
département je rappelle mais vous avez
aussi ce mandat de conseillère
départementale
ces outils du numérique pour l'éducation
vous y croyez profondément sahel a
révolutionné sa doivent ça doit
révolutionner l'éducation oui c'est une
révolution
le numérique est partout dans nos vies
aujourd'hui pourquoi l'école passerait à
travers les mailles du filet pour pour
le numérique on s'aperçoit au fur et à
mesure des expérimentations que l'on
mène que le numérique apporte aux
enfants confiance en soi concentration
et et mon objectif bien sûr c'est de
faire réussir les enfants les résultats
internationaux de la france aura passé
pencher dessus mais ne sont pas bons
septième au classement 25e au classement
international pisa
donc il faut vraiment faire faire des
choses et on a de la chance sur le
territoire parce qu'on a un partenaire
très très fort avec l'éducation
nationale qui partagent nos idées et qui
nous aide à mettre en place ces projets
là donc les projets ça fait plus de dix
ans maintenant que on les a mis en place
sur elancourt encore une fois en
partenariat avec l'éducation nationale
on avait affaire au départ à des
enseignants que t'es pas forcément
attirés par par le sujet mais ils sont
venu petit à petit et c'est grâce à eux
d'ailleurs que maintenant et l'encours
est quand même un modèle national et
voir au delà puisque on a des visites
internationales qui viennent voir nos
écoles et qui viennent voir un petit peu
les projets que l'on met en place
donc maintenant l'idée c'est on a
développé sur elancourt au niveau du
conseil départemental
je participe effectivement à ce projet
de développement du numérique dans les
collèges puisque c'est donc une
compétence du conseil départemental et
donc avec la création du volet numérique
qui fait que ça facilite beaucoup le
déploiement de ces projets auprès des
communes et maintenant l'idée c'est de
le développer sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines pour pouvoir avoir
une continuité d'apprentissage et on a
des ambitions très forte puisque avec
l'éducation nationale on aimerait
développer de la maternelle jusqu'à
l'université puisque paris saclay est
quand même un pôle universitaire
importante sur le territoire et vous
avez le sentiment d'être suivi aussi par
le gouvernement actuel sur ces sujets là
alors le nouveau ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur blanc caire est
quelqu'un que j'apprécie beaucoup
il a participé d'ailleurs aux missions
parlementaires de jean michel fourgous à
l'époque il était à la dsp enfin
des natures partager ses idées de
l'apport du numérique
dans l'école donc
oui pour moi c'est un bon ministre et on
a de bonnes de bonne de bon partage sur
ce sujet là au niveau de la politique on
parlait de ce dossier du numérique de
l'éducation qui sont les deux sujets à
vos deux sujets de prédilection est ce
qu il yad autres thèmes d'autres
d'autres fibres que vous avez en
politique de dossiers que vous souhaitez
faire avancer ou l'éducation me prend
beaucoup de temps
c'est déjà trop faire ce qu'il ya de
quoi faire donc il ya il ya beaucoup de
choses à apporter
depuis je suis conseillère ginette
départementale pardon il ya tous les
sujets aussi des deux sociale qui
m'intéresse c'est d'actualité puisque on
en parle au gouvernement en ce moment
mais de tous les fléchages des aides
sociales qui sont qui sont donnés en
france je pense qu'on pourrait mieux les
flécher mieux les accompagner et surtout
mieux accompagner les les ayants droit
pour pouvoir considérer qu'une aide
sociale c'est un palier mais ça ne doit
pas être pérenne et ça doit aider nos
concitoyens à à rebondir dans la vie est
ce que vous exprimez vous pouvez une
certaine lassitude en politique déjà ou
pas du tout non non non pas du tout au
contraire je trouve que on vit des
moments difficiles
et justement ça donne encore plus envie
de se battre et de et de faire des
choses pour que pour que pour améliorer
la vie de nos concitoyens je considère
le travail d'élu mois comme sur le
terrain je n'aurais pas accepté
n'importe quel délégation pour moi un
élu c'est quelqu'un qui doit être sur le
terrain qui doit connaître les gens
individuellement si possible les aider
on est là pour rendre service aux gens
et moi ça me passionne ça veut dire
qu'un prochain mandat n'est pas exclure
une prochaine candidature annonce sûr
que non mais on entendait des listes
déposées
je ne brigue pas forcément une tête de
liste non à ce que je veux encore une
fois c'est être utile pour pour les
administrés
je pense qu'un poste de maire-adjoint
est un poste important et que j'ai mon
rôle à jouer
dans ce domaine là et non tête de liste
pas forcément mais pourquoi pas donc non
ne faites pas dire ce que je ne veux pas
dire jeu on aura le temps d'en parler
dit si d'ici là oui bien sûr voilà les
choses avancent avance vite
la situer les situations changent et si
un jour on me demandait
et si on disait vraiment on a besoin de
toi pour sûr mais ici pas le 15 on va
terminer par un questionnaire rapide
comme à chaque fois dans cette émission
votre livre de chevet alors le livre de
chevet salive ou sur lequel je reviens
régulièrement en fait s'appelle la
petite poussette de michel serres et la
petite poussette en fait ça bien du du
numérique encore en fait c'est le petit
poucet parce que les jeunes pousses sur
les tablettes
et il explique très bien et très
simplement la transformation de la
société avec le numérique et je trouve
que c'est bien de s'y remettre de temps
en temps et c'est très instructif
le dernier film que vous ayez vu au
cinéma alors c'est encore un film que
j'ai revu et j'aime beaucoup les petits
mouchoirs de guillaume canet je trouve
que c'est une bonne étude de la société
de l'amitié de la solidarité
il s'est dit des choses très très vrai
les artistes musicale du moment pour
vous alors ou alors aussi présent en ce
moment je suis branché katie melua est
une jeune artiste canadienne qui chante
du jazz et du blues et et voilà je suis
beaucoup en voiture et ça me détend
énormément merci beaucoup un carrefour
de la voir participer au café politique
à bientôt
[Musique]
et